I almost think it's seven o'clock in the
morning and Elon Musk anxiously waits
for his golden payoff his prize for
paying his dues in the valley I expected
to receive a call that I have just
bought which is called McLaren f1 it's a
million dollars record it's it's it's
decadent there are 62 returns in the
world and I'm wonderful back in 95 they
weren't very many people on the Internet
and certainly nobody was making any
money at all most people thought the
internet was gonna be a fad not this
South African entrepreneur musk sold his
first computer program at the age of 12
and he hasn't stopped selling since Wow
company that's actually here that's
pretty well but just three years ago I
was showering in that at the Y and
sleeping on the office floor and now
obviously I've got a million our car and
quite a few creature comforts it's just
some moments in my life
my values may have changed but I'm not
consciously aware of my values having
changed my fear is that we become
spoiled brats that we lose a sense of
appreciation and perspective a year ago
must sold his software company zip to
which enabled newspapers to publish
online for four hundred million dollars
cash receiving cash is cash I mean those
are just a large number of Ben
Franklin's it's a perfect car for
Silicon Valley it really is
there is gel in the fastest car in the
world I could go and buy one of the
islands of the Bahamas and turn it into
my personal fiefdom I'm much more
interested in trying to build and create
a new company so this is an ATM what
we're gonna do is transform the
traditional banking industry
I do not fit the picture of a banker
raising 50 million dollars is a matter
of making a series of phone calls and
the money is there I've sunk the great
majority of my net worth into XCOM which
is the new banking and mutual funds
company on the internet that I've
started I think XCOM could absolutely be
a multi-billion dollar bonanza because
if you look at the industry that X is
pursuing it's the biggest sector of the
world economy is that I McLaren f1 yes
oh my god
that's a light series of poker games and
now I've gone on to a more high stakes
game and just carry those chips with me
and I haven't gone in taking my winnings
this Manovich check but I've just really
put almost all of it back into the new
game no I'd say the real payoff is the
sense of satisfaction having created
it's the company that I sold with the
car honest sure is you take the car
they talk tenías people who have hit the
jackpot surely they don't even have a
conceptualization of the money that they
have it's funny money it's double unity
to think about the amazing thing is it
almost none of them quit even when they
could it's not a vesting thing it's not
that there's some secret clause in there
that keeps them from doing it they want
to do what they're doing they think that
just stop doing that is death I'd like
to be on the cover of Rolling Stone
that'd be cool
then what you've got going on with the
internet is it's basically like an
earthquake where the epicenter is
Silicon Valley and it's it's shaking up
the whole world so this is still a new
series for me I'd love to know if you
like it if I should continue with
profiling different entrepreneurs and
their young starts let me know in the
comments below and if you want to see
the last one I did on Jeff Bezos from
his 1997 interview go check out the link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there where did you get an idea for
amazon.com well three years ago I was in
New York City working for a quantitative
hedge fund